everybody what's going on bleh here
welcome to stream Coco yeah we're super
excited because two-time WWE Divas champ
Paige is with us we're gonna be playing
WWE 2k16 oh my god
it's amazing now first of all I've known
Xavier woods in this game okay I haven't
I haven't been on his shirt up up down
down but I will try she's gonna try
she's gonna succeed I'm terrible at
wrestling do you like this I'm really
hot but I just want to get it yes and
they brought this giant belt that weighs
a million pounds this thing is really
can you hear that
he's just an Olympic all that these are
my knuckles breaking continue doing
exactly all right so we're gonna play
we're gonna play WWE 2k16 hey but hey
guys what's going on oh my god love you
Paige play set there's no Seth here so
but yes so hit us with your questions
we're here for the next 30 minutes I've
got you for 30 minutes
Wow don't worry it'll crawl good a drag
alright so here we go so pick your pick
your person so hit let's see let's do
this and I hit X yeah alright then
select superstar or diva maybe let's
even pages in this game by the way what
you should play alright first of all
don't tell me how to live second of all
thank you I'm sassy all right oh you
scared of even Murray should be oh I
just mean a tie his way better than me
no fair enough
that's a nice you do know I should I had
a manager know oh wait should you have a
manager yeah no I should have imagined
all right fair enough I'll go no manager
you come in so this is this game is
super exciting because this year they've
added even more amazing characters so
this is the largest roster I think
there's over 120 characters the largest
roster today
Vince oh there oh sure oh yeah there you
go come perfect perfect I tend to button
mash so they rip Bob
hey Bob Bob ran us through all the
controls earlier yeah I just knew I was
gonna but not exactly if I was a
wrestler
weeping softly in the corner followed by
followed by reading quietly to myself in
the locker room how did you come by the
way how did you come up with how do you
come up with your own special moves how
does that work oh I just steal a
restless oh there we go
[Music]
hey all right keep your eyes to yourself
this is this is how I look in a red
bikini by the way normally I just want
to put that out there one new thing too
is you can run in if you just hit X
which is kind of cool you need a hurry
up I know it's that I gotta get my
sweaty in that but it's got to go back
and forth
that's my intimidation snake hips
exactly yeah so I got my finisher from
bull Nakano which is the submission
which I'm probably gonna beat you with
probably well actually I got Barbie in
real life maybe not in-game we'll see
but you know I will probably pretty much
sky you from this are you in competitive
are you nervous right now
I'm free too well are you oh my god
that's it oh I put it I was like dogs
I'm gonna go to Title I yes I dig this
Ken whoa it was cool you have to like
like like well they have a thing that
goes all the way around your head and
then you have to like pull faces like ah
really and then you have to hold it for
like good 10 seconds it's the most
awkward thing everybody's God it's
deafening experience and then you stand
with like about 100 lights and cameras
around you and they just take pictures
do they make you wear one of the skin
tights used to the ping-pong balls or
whatever do you have to wear one of
those suits of the ping-pong balls I'm I
don't I don't know
we'll have people do it live well
gimmick on and they'll do our moves for
us because I was gonna say it might be
kind of cool if you wrestled in the ping
pong ball suit you know like I mean yeah
that's it that's good that could be
here's we're gonna see I'll page by the
ways on the show tonight as well as why
she's gracing us with her presence today
so watch the show this evening but
you'll notice when you meet Conan it's
really weird he's just a head in legs
like he's just like he's very skinny and
he's just like you could break him in
half here we go don't worry all right so
we got a hit you have to hit one of
those you play rock paper scissors why
is that so many buttons it's human
gridlock that's what they're calling our
match human gridlock I love the way that
hair looks by the way in this Oh oh
whoops that's me that's me no that was
me no no wait don't don't restart match
I was just I was just trying to forget
that I just ha ha boom take that sucker
yeah yeah yeah all right you know yeah
Oh what now
Oh see I will sky you from its perish
for you
ah how does that feel writing it away
you have two kidneys you don't need that
one here we go take that take it oh it's
too many here we go oh oh
nice reversal yeah I see you have that
game see you I got one sad I'm John I
ready for this he's that she's suplexes
me oh I'm trying to have you guys have
questions for Paige please I need
something to distract her I'm getting my
oh oh he'll spin that's my own there
take your take rat take this I'm gonna
start this I'm gonna start my special oh
right guess sucka
oh my god yeah I don't even mess with me
are you what is the what is the most
painful move to get put on you oh I'm
relieved my urn has that ever happened
to anyone use your own ash
daddy that they wouldn't dare are you
kidding me yeah don't even don't even
try and escape this take on take I know
it looks like a kit like even mine ever
looks like you're beating me up but I'm
just resting really I didn't get a lot
of sleep last night just go to sleep
I was I was watching Grey's Anatomy I'm
just taking it here we go here we go you
ready for this No now what yeah yeah
good night that's too close that's what
I did to back me up
that's what Bane did Batman right I know
I want you wait I'm okay with being with
Bane because he is a babe
even with that mask ease yeah exactly no
wait I have a question you what are you
Halloween's coming up what are you gonna
be for Halloween are you a dresser opera
oh oh you know I certainly try this and
try doing that now go in there x-pac
sorry Circle thanks Bob how do we get
back in Bob lol one oh that one there we
go there we go she's back alright no
look at this I'm literally just getting
lucky with the button hey Vince can you
help a brother out or not exactly I do
not I don't usually no I do not usually
if you keep drop kicking me let me just
help you I'm well thank you it's good
what the hair-pulling izzle that's gotta
hurt right come on
that's not cool the hair pull somebody
else no no no you're about to get killed
right now it doesn't look like you're
slapping a bit oh wait I take it oh wait
those no this is great
no this is great no I want to switch
controllers no all right
she's getting violent you saw that yeah
yeah I get competitive yeah this is I'm
just trying to crack you see this
backhand it's gonna go interesting I'm
just doing to crack you back
the damage has been done they're saying
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I actually am terribly no you stay well
how do I do this again sore winner
Nikolas did you realize how by the
entire hey the shake oh yes and that's
the highlight they show us from a body
slam a limp and I can't feel my nerve
damage no it didn't feel good I got butt
slam it did not feel good
there's a nice I hope you guys are happy
we didn't cheat at all we were exactly
oh my god people people can't wait to
meet you they love you what about me I
just got destroyed all right fine
fair enough all right do you want to
make a character so we make it why don't
we make a character sure that's just we
got the old finger point going on just
you guys are sitting boyd's all right
all right here we go Wow I'm exact it
was physically exhausting all right or
she was just play again Helen
so that's coming up to Sunday I hope
you're ready for this I'm ready I'm
always ready to lose that's not a good
thing to say good trash so good at you
I'm constantly ready to lose yeah all
right all right you know what I've had
it that's right guess what now guess
what should I wait should we be super
let's be super super super oh my god I'd
love to go all the way back here we go
yeah by the way this story mode on this
on this game is based on song cold yeah
pretty great oh oh it's gonna be it's
your Halloween costume it's my Halloween
costume are you ready for you what's
your best selling everything I've never
taken versus my god this was a hot time
last year whoa great minds think alike
you are best friends man I'm kidding
completely sold out the people in the
back are just horrified horrified you
should be so when I veneks t maybe Enzo
and all right Enzo amore Wow this dude's
hair is amazing I'm so jealous kind of
like the weekend he kind of reminds me a
guy fieri just a little bit in the best
way possible and the best way possible
all right all right audience see us
right now mm-hmm
they can see us they could see ya they
can see us kinda behind the thing yeah
they're all on their hands nodding
old-fashioned so yeah hashtag bleed
justice ass kicked make sure you tweet
about it yeah there's like oh my god I'm
embarrassed for him
[Laughter]
pretty good like you wrap it yourself
yeah finally I finally you know I feel
like I would be a pretty good rapper I
think you should try it
you know like DJ bleh like I would
something about my snow cap I could be
the right gray hair snow cap have you a
rapper what's your rap name be yeah I
ask the hard gettin down to the core of
although she hasn't answered it has she
no I haven't exactly so don't know
uh-huh just say page all right let's see
if someone give me no I don't your album
name would be turn the page it's that
easy
well page Hey Oh see page turners hey
can someone give me a rap a name please
yeah jack over the rack give her a
rapper name exactly oh my god let Beth
play no that's horrified
what should Paige wrap a name be exactly
come on yeah good lord
Oh people want Smackdown spoiler G dog
dog P dogs pretty great P dog P dizzle
page e on it that's not good
P shizzle P chisel white lightening
could be for either of us I would be
cool P P even and I sound like urine man
look at he's got what is this what is
this muscle what is this muscle that I
don't have that he has lots the last
that's pretty good rampage is great
rampage alright I'll be called rampage
webpages awesome
that kind of I don't want to rip on
Brock cuz he'll rip my head off
yeah but you could say that that sword
tattoo and I thought when I seen this of
him in person kind of looks like the
head of a guitar yeah kind of does a
little bit yeah oh yeah is it I'm saying
oh yeah I want somebody to like before
they go to body slamming like
like drop it yeah just as like a double
a double slam if you can watch this yeah
cuz that's what we want is brought to
watch this and just watch I'm sure you
watch stuff like this it's been this in
half with one hand that way I want to go
to suplex see just to try look at that
stare like can you get me you got a
pretty intimidating stir no all right
you ready I'm gonna give it to camera
I'm gonna you look in here I'm gonna
give it to cameras having a good see it
ready I'm gonna look back nerdy oh
there's that cry in the corner yeah good
you you feel bad for me you want to give
me money or help me I feel like yeah I
would be good if I leave here you're
like see how could anyone be that sad
yeah I'm like oh my gosh yeah sorry it's
game time shut up all right I'm sorry
yeah oh jeez you're really ruining my
rap career I didn't want I didn't want
kids anyway oh my god you're already
pinning me here we got backup now you're
like yeah that's yeah take that take
that
the worst part is you're not having
showered in like a week the worst part
of that is oh yeah yeah I'm not just a
mess I mean pages brother
I'm eating my butt that's my best asset
oh I hope it of back so you hook rabbit
punches oh no guarding me I'm just
tickling you get out his son trickling
you I said oh you want to take a seat
there you get up here we go
what about a little if you were worth oh
you're right professional term ring I
don't know already said she did it I
didn't only wanted it once oh wait hold
on I'm back you are super competitive
but guys were playing she's inching
closer to the camera
not the moneymaker oh I was about to
jump in you you say still wasn't sure
what you Stacey Jeremy you just did yeah
you just did even me right yeah you know
I'm just gonna work out some of these
kinks in your back don't worry about it
pretty good here we go
our reversals limited in this iteration
yes you have five reversals that you
build them up more as your one taker so
guys I'm trying you guys I'm trying to
be I'm actually trying I'm not even
kidding
just embarrassing for me boo don't like
city oh yeah you want this you want this
I don't want this I'm extremely not
happy I'm not you know what okay you
know what one more match and then we're
calling it this is we only have time for
one more quick match my I think I'm
going to win this match
why here's why because I'm gonna have a
manager who's gonna help me out oh yeah
I've never had a manager I need someone
to distract you from punching me in the
face all right well the back over and
over you need someone who's you're
really bad okay are you you know what
let's just rematch it let's have we get
not to do here let's just you do
audience I do love real quick laughs
themselves I should show them my sad
face then they probably laugh all right
forget it let's just rematch it very
quickly you're ready yes
with Enzo yeah with Enzo and so Enzo
needs to prepare himself yeah all right
let's do this
that was embarrassing incident cry again
you're watching Oh what have you what
are you now
now what oh look at these Musa he's
gonna get murdered
Oh
[Music]
now there's no need for name-calling oh
really
all right now that you found that pin
button Bob why did we tell her how to
pin me we shouldn't have told her Thank
You TRO Mike he's like just leave well
enough alone all right
Paige best docs on Twitch loves you huh
yeah oh there we go
Oh punch you in the face I'm not even
kidding
Enzo needs to stop dancing every time I
press the punch button he dances press
with the screen says I'm trying pop
don't understand you are soft this
doesn't work too good this thing up here
don't work he's so goody ok happy
birthday that's what I'm going to say
what I'm doing really well happy
birthday that's a good time what's a
good time just casually walk back in
here ok I'm just dancing up here I can't
make this guy stop dancing yep
oh well done yeah what's that I want to
show the German it can you just keep
still so I can give you a gentleman oh
you know what else is cool look it
there's slap marks on your on your your
man chest oh is that what's called a man
chest I don't have just Chad can you
Wikipedia man that's not everybody
everybody's send page your energy so she
can win seriously all right wait here we
go all right all right you know what I'm
calling it I can't I think three three
zero all right the game is wwe2k16 it
comes out on Tuesday in the US and on
the 30th everywhere else follow page
real page WWE on Instagram and Twitter
and follow WWE games and look at her
helena sell this Sunday at 8:00 yeah
thank you for joining us and we will see
you guys Monday for scream caucus you
guys later bye watch the show tonight
watch me watch me
you